well i have a bag of mail to review with
you it's not a literal bag it's a
proverbial bag but it's a bag
nonetheless you can email info
davidpakman.com if you would like to get
a message through to us it may be
featured on an upcoming episode it may
not uh i'm going to start with um this
is this has to be a presented without
comment because it's so wacky but this
is the sort of thing that i get every
day and one of the things that i wonder
about is
what must be going on
in this person's life
to think to write such a message to
someone they don't know
um hey you racist liberal lunatics peter
puffer communist socialist socialism
culture f that's the f word
i hope you boy biden f's you you life
and all around you up
cuz if you retards not a word i use it's
just verbatim because if you retards
believe that woman testimony in that s
show here what somebody told somebody
told somebody i overheard that
you all bunch of butt buddy do each
other off air
so would you say this is truth
i would not say this is truth
i would not say that this message
contains truth
the profile image has
a nascar vehicle
for this person who wrote in
all right folks let's continue it's
crazy out there a dwayne wrote in and
says i can't believe you still defend
this gene therapy
so dave
you're getting the fifth or the sixth i
assume they mean vaccines i don't know
dwayne says anyway this is old news but
i wanted your opinion on a list of
things trump did just a few things to
show he actually took them on the elite
obama hillary pelosi blah blah
the cutting taxes and regulations for
small business i couldn't tell exactly
what taxes but did he cut him
the person seems very confident in their
confusion
some people said they benefited more
money in their pockets never mind the
debt 25 trillion to china funding the
war in afghan and iraq okay never mind
that
did you get more money did he lower
taxes
my grammar is not the best i have common
sense over you high intellects with
degrees you can't get that from college
and i use short form like you and
couldn't okay i'm not putting quotation
marks like you freaks
i once met someone who used quotation
marks they were a freak that's true
sec cut funding from who not on the
agenda
if people think he's with them a
globalist whatever
globalists don't agree with some of
things he did so first is cut taxes
second is cut money from who third cut
funding from nato not on the agenda u.s
was paying the most not part of eu not
on the ag so that's four so now five
nafta scrapped it yes he agreed to
another crappy deal but not on the ag6
obamacare which is scam
but i had a better one so we'll say five
for now
eu cut funding can't remember details
but was getting out if had one again
that's six
there was one more can't remember can
you comment on those six
i can destroy the
sc failed vaccine and the fake pandemic
covet is real the word pandemic is fake
that's another topic
don't comment on my grammar
instead of a comma i can double tap the
space bar and it's a period
i'm on my phone wow folks i can't do it
i think i might have to quit these
emails are driving me into retirement
all right now for some more substantive
things santa wrote in hey david assuming
democrats don't fight away find a way to
codify roe v wade into law anytime in
the near future do you think states
where abortion is legal
will have an entire industry of abortion
clinics start to develop along their
borders with states where it's illegal
if so what other things do you foresee
happening yeah this is interesting
because it reminds me when i grew up in
massachusetts it was known
fireworks were really i don't know if
they're still illegal in massachusetts
fireworks were illegal in massachusetts
but legal in new hampshire so there
would be fireworks stores
right on the border of new hampshire and
massachusetts and people would drive
there it almost seems certain
that we will see something similar with
abortion how would we not how would we
not
and the question that remains is whether
states that ban abortion
will try to prosecute those who leave
the state and legally get an abortion
elsewhere i don't think there's really a
legal basis for that
i've spoken to lawyers and they've not
they've not articulated to me how would
you do that if you go to a state where
an abortion is legal
it's sort of like if you go to
i don't know if you go to amsterdam
and consume cannabis where it's legal
and then come back to the us
to a state where it's illegal could the
state prosecute you for what you did in
amsterdam doesn't seem like it
so that's a question but uh i think you
will indeed see such a
such an industry develop and it's a
horrible thing to think about
mark wrote in about hearsay and asked hi
david is cassidy hutchinson's testimony
hearsay please share your thoughts if
you have a minute it seems part of it
could be and part of it not thanks for
all you do and congratulations on your
baby so there's two answers to this
question
is so hearsay is a legal term relevant
in courts of law
so the first question is why are we even
talking about hearsay in a congressional
hearing hearsay is allowed in
congressional hearings so
that's not an issue
second part there are people who when
they say is it hearsay
you can tell believe that if it's
hearsay it can't be believed
sometimes hearsay is true
and so
whether or not it's hearsay is a
different question from whether or not
cassidy hutchinson's testimony was
accurate
and then third even in courts of law
there are dozens of hearsay exemptions
or exceptions wherein hearsay is allowed
so
yes cassidy because some of cassidy
hutchinson's testimony
if presented in a court of law would be
hearsay that has no bearing on its truth
and it has no bearing on whether it is
acceptable in a congressional uh hearing
matt rodin
a comment on tucker's june 28 show
hi sir heard your show on john eastman
on tucker's show tucker said they're
treating eastman like a drug kingpin or
a rapist shouldn't he have said a drunk
drug kingpin or a woman who just had an
illegal abortion i believe the
punishment is far worse
that than the actual rapist just a
thought yeah so
i think the point being made here by
matt
is
there are many who want to criminalize
abortion usually they stop short of
saying uh criminalize the woman's action
they will often say criminalize the
doctor
uh etc but point well taken they are
sort of relegating women
seeking medical services
to uh criminals
and that's crazy
a few other aggressive ones
whose payroll are you on a whole no
matter what they're paying you you're
going against your country you piece of
s
f u
uh i'm not on anyone's payroll other
than yours
it's the people in the audience who
support the work that we do
so i guess i'm on my own payroll in that
i own my own business
and i'm on the payroll of the audience
because the audience funds the show
beyond that you know whenever people
talk about
soros or
whoever else is paying me
prove it prove someone other than the
audience
and our few advertisers are paying me
please
uh do you guys get triggered much
because it seems like you do
do you care on all the riots the
democrats did for the last six years
i'll wait for your response
well
i have unequivocally
denounced violence
and uh it has been something i've said
regardless of who's doing it or the
political orientation of those doing it
we know that in the united states the
overwhelming majority of politically
motivated violence is perpetrated by the
right not by the left
democrats did riots for six years you're
gonna have to remind me about that
when there has been violence or
criminality at whatever protest black
lives matter entrepha anything uh i say
i'm against that and if crimes have been
committed then people should be dealt
with in the criminal justice system
and we saw nothing from them
like what we saw on january 6. so i hope
that you weren't waiting too long
and i hope that i answered your question
last one
you have a chance to see two thousand
mules but i think you're while you are
afraid to watch
and read the laptop from hell
your president and his nasty son
all over it
i have now talked about 2 000 mules
three times i think that is more than
sufficient for
how rigorous it is three times i've
spoken about 2000 mules
i have spoken about the hunter biden
laptop now probably closer to six or
seven times
i've basically said everything i think
should be said about it based on what we
know so far
if you think there's something specific
that should be said that i haven't said
let me know maybe even call into the
show we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today
sign up at
joinpakman.com that's p a k m a n dot
com to get instant access to the bonus
show you also get the daily podcast in
either audio or video form whichever
form you prefer
when you're a member
that podcast full show is made available
to you five or six hours earlier than we
publish it to everybody else
and when we do our town hall events you
get priority access when you are a
member join pacman.com coupon code big
voting22
we will see you on the bonus show and
then we will see you next week